so what does all of this mean matt
whitaker is former acting attorney
general and he joins us now matt great
to see you tonight
this is
i i think it's fair to say without
exaggeration this is big tell us what
you read into what's happening in the
durham investigation in the trial of
michael sussman as of today
yeah this sussman trial is so important
for two reasons one it's holding
somebody accountable for lying the fbi
and upholding the rule of law but on the
other hand it is also important because
it is telling the story of what the
clinton campaign did as spreading
disinformation uh really that was
in 2017 that our current national
security adviser jake sullivan was
talking about this same fake news false
information that hillary clinton had
ordered the code red to disseminate to
the media and sussman prior to that had
gone to the fbi and saying i don't
represent any uh clients but he did he
represented the campaign when he
delivered this information to the fbi
yeah that i i don't think that can go
without being highlighted what you just
said jake sullivan the man we just saw
lying on national television is the one
in charge of giving us daily updates on
the war in ukraine that is the man in
charge in a large part of our national
security now but matt where do you think
this goes from here there's a sense
among many watching that this is just
the beginning of john durham's
investigation now that michael sussman
is on trial we'll see where that verdict
comes in but where does it go from here
after sussman
yeah i think it's going to go
to a broader group that was involved in
creating this
disinformation because if you remember
in durham's filings before the trial
started he suggested there was a joint
venture or a criminal conspiracy among
several people to execute this plan
of lying to the fbi and trying to launch
a investigation that would lead to this
october surprise so i think it's going
to continue
to go slow but intentionally
try to cast a net that's broader than
just michael sussman does that let's
leave it here matt with this question
does that net
does that net get cast wide enough that
it does land
over hillary clinton
well like you said earlier
robbie mook testified today in court
that hillary clinton said share this
disinformation
with the media and remember these are
the same people that had the
disinformation about hunter's laptop so
i think durham is finally going to make
a statement to many of these people that
this type of lying to the american
people is over
we can only hope
matt whitaker thank you so much
thank you will
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight